[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
thank you so much for coming please hit
the Subscribe button all of these
subscriptions just really point me in
the right direction with the guests and
also help us get bigger names so really
really appreciate that today on the show
is Robert Breedlove he is an extremely
intelligent man who's been reading since
he was a little kid about things like
astrophysics he has a podcast called
what is money he considers himself a
freedom maximalist and is a philosopher
of Bitcoin we might have to rethink
money we might not actually have what we
think we do it might not be as stable as
we think it is wow I finally feel like I
have a little bit of a grasp of digital
currency and why it's important please
enjoy this episode and let me know what
you think in the comments uh yeah I love
that expression I'm sure I'm going to
get it a little bit off but it's
basically that if you can't explain
something simply you don't understand it
well enough and I'd say that's true
because anything that I stumble on I
mean immediately have to say I'm working
through this like I don't completely
comprehend it myself and I'm working
through it but yeah that's interesting
to have that sort of three-step process
that you have and I'm sure it's not like
you did it because you knew it would
work it just seems to be a a pathway to
really understanding something yeah it
just happened organically like I've been
reading my whole life but I didn't start
writing until really getting into
Bitcoin I was reading a lot about
Bitcoin when you first go into the the
Bitcoin Rabbit Hole as we call it I was
just consuming a lot of content and then
I was like okay I need to stop and get
clear on what I've been learning the
past year and a half to two years
so trying to write it all down and
synthesize it
and then that was painful but useful
and then just by happenstance people
would I published the things that I
wrote and people in Bitcoin circles read
the things that I wrote they liked it
they invited me on their podcast to talk
about it
and so after going through that just
again not I didn't know that was a path
to like
embedding your learning in a very unique
way but I learned it just sort of
organically
and now
I try to do it more consciously but
again writing I don't know I'm
I feel like I can only do kind of one
thing at a time so when I'm in podcast
mode and I'm recording with guests every
day I'm in that mode but then when I'm
not recording with guests every day I
can get into writing mode and I'm like
thinking about the writing all the time
writing reading
I have a hard time doing two things at
once so still trying to figure out that
trick
I can't do that either if somebody
starts talking to me and I'm on my phone
I'm just I just immediately tell them
something that simple I'm like I can't
hear you yeah I'm looking at my phone
right now doing two things at once but
it's probably also because you go so
deep like I mean you're
you're not reading the Dr Seuss of
Bitcoin books or writing it you're you
know this stuff is like complicated this
stuff is intricate I mean you know I I'm
fascinated with how you know I know you
have a degree in in Finance and
Accounting but I I I'm fascinated with
how much you know about
sort of Consciousness and
ancient history and psychology and
philosophizing like that sort of um and
how you pick the path of money or if
maybe money came first that realm and
then these other interests came in
um I'm kind of really fascinated because
you seem like you have
I mean maybe my level's not as high as
yours but fairly insatiable mind yeah I
think so I mean I I really
it feels like working out to me and I'm
also very addicted to working out I just
like to push myself and I like the
feeling of
you know with physical training it's
almost like the
the counter move to the cognitive
training like you work with your brain
all day you know you're sitting and
reading and talking and thinking it's
like you kind of overheat the
the brain
yeah the risk there is you might tend to
become more overthinking and I was
definitely I've had phases in my life
where I was very much an overthinker
especially my my early years
prior to discovering like yoga and
meditation helped me a lot with
overthinking
um
but the physical training gives you the
counterbalance to that where you can
just go be fully in your body you know
you kind of like again once I learned
about meditation I started to combine
that with working out
it's like I'm matching my breath and my
movement in the gym I'm trying to
meditate into the pain like the more it
hurts the more the discomfort comes up
you kind of go into that
and so it really like forces you to get
completely out of your mind like a
moving meditation yeah exactly exactly
and did you play sports
yeah I did so I did uh football and
wrestling when I was young and then I
got into Olympic style weightlifting
which was my main sport from the age of
13 to 17. I competed internationally and
I was really into that wow Olympic
weightlifting for people that don't know
what that is it's uh the lifts you
typically see in CrossFit so the
explosive overhead lifts
yeah yes but
snatch and clean and jerk are the
competitive lifts but we did everything
in training right dead left squats did
you watch the CrossFit games this
weekend no I did not I was there
um I've done CrossFit on I mean I did it
for solely for a long time and
kind of beat my body into the ground so
I just lift now
um
what's uh what was your uh what was your
clean and jerk and what was your my best
list so I was
in the 105 kilo weight class so 230
pounds
I stopped when I was 17 and my best
lifts were 147 kilo snatch which is like
325 I think oh yeah that's
at the top of what they were doing yeah
and then a 182 kilo clean and jerk which
is like just under right at 400 pounds
yep somebody did I think maybe
396. yeah and if like real Olympic
lifters can do a lot like they have
great videos on Instagram if you've
never seen them that um it's a cool
sport but I don't it's
not super fun to watch unless you're
into it because you got to kind of
understand the technique and the
challenge of the lifts if you're just
watching it without any of that
first-hand experience it's yeah just
watching someone throw some weight over
their head
um yeah yeah yeah you don't understand
how hard it is yeah it's all a technique
I like to push myself I guess and maybe
that's for my athletic background but
pushing myself physically in the gym and
then with with reading there's just so
many big ideas out there and
um I like to read really hard esoteric
non-fiction books I don't know when I
was young and my mom got me into reading
initially she was basically saying look
any problem you have or anything you're
curious about
this is how you solve the problem or
this is how you associate the curiosity
is like you can just grab books and you
can find books on anything anywhere and
so my initial curiosity when I was a kid
was about the stars and the cosmos and
space and all that so started reading
astrophysics and all that when I was
like 11 12 13.
which is amazing I still very fascinated
by that topic I don't read as much about
it anymore but um and then later on I
got into I was very mystified with like
people talk about stock markets and
equities and bonds and
and I'm like what is all that like
doesn't make any sense to me like what
are all these weird abstract Concepts
that people are
like really making a big deal about
they're you know people get really swept
up in what they own and buying and
selling and trading but I couldn't
really understand what that meant like
in particular a stock certificate I was
like what is a stock what does that mean
you just like own little pieces of
something on a piece of paper like how
does that
so I started going into the like the
economics and money rabbit hole and
I guess to answer your question like
which came first
um really money like actually getting
when I read the book The Creature From
Jekyll Island by G Edward Griffin
it's a great book it's about the
Inception of the Federal Reserve in the
U.S it's about the nature of Central
Banking in general uh he actually has a
chapter or at least a segment in that
book titled what is money so he goes
into the nature of money itself
which I didn't know that until I reread
the book about six months ago so I'm not
sure if the inspiration for the show
came exactly this
slanted yeah
topic because it's it's like it's
obviously not just paper right because
the paper is like like this is
nothing right it's a symbolism it's the
purpose of it it's how it came about
it's the reason why it's the the way it
becomes corrupted and you know it's
everything is a reflection on other
things so it's a much deeper topic than
just
money money the way yeah and it's a hard
question to answer like after three
years of doing the show
we've accumulated a lot of answers to
the question and a lot you know a lot of
them make sense in their own right
but none of them are comprehensive well
when you ask these other fundamental
questions right what is freedom what is
truth what is love you know you you're
like oh it's so obvious but then you try
to really answer it and articulate it
and you end up with a diatribe right
there's a bunch of answers a bunch of
different perspectives on it truth is a
great one right it's like that should be
the most obvious thing in the world just
but philosophers have been writing about
the nature of Truth for hundreds and
hundreds of years and no one's really
settled on what it is like you can't
capture it in words per se to understand
money best analogy is probably to
something like language it's a symbolic
technology or or a symbolic structure uh
John verakee calls it a psycho
technology
so whereas a normal technology improves
your physical fitness to the world right
a shovel lets you dig more holes with
less effort something like that
a psycho technology improves your
cerebral Fitness to the world
so in the case of language right we can
map reality we can map our experiences
and encode it into written or audio form
such that we can communicate with one
another about it it's like it's like
data compression so we have experience
that feeds our perceptions and then the
perceptions can be fed into conceptions
the conceptions are encoded in language
and we can use that to both think
internally right so we can analyze
reflect on our experience we can look
into the future money is like the medium
of exchange for Human Action is telling
you what what actually has been done
right what favors an entrepreneur has
rendered to the market how many favors
the market sort of owes him back in in
the form of his saved purchasing power
and uh and it helps coordinate Human
Action right it's what coordinates the
entire Market process
we all kind of get out of bed in the
morning typically to go do something for
money like unless you're on vacation and
you're spending money you're probably
going to work and making money
um yeah yeah that's true they're
spending it or making it usually yeah so
it's very we're very much immersed in
this economic ether
we're thinking through it actually just
like we think through language so when
you're
calculating negotiating or executing a
trade or you know looking am I going to
buy this house am I going to buy this
car am I going to go on this trip like
you're actually thinking in prices
relative to how much money you have so
it's a it's a cognitive tool right what
perfect you would call a psycho
technology
but it's a little bit strange because
where language is purely
a cognitive tool there's no physical
manifestation of English right that
where where is the English language
it's nowhere it's just kind of the
software money does have a routing to
physical reality and historically that
rooting was was gold
or commodity monies and it needed to
have that rooting because
money has to be scarce it has to be
physically constrained from
overproduction because if you over over
produce the money you hyperinflate it
right you dilute it you mean when you
put money yes
so again money is a strange one it's
like part psycho technology part
physical technology because it needed to
be rooted in physics
such that we don't over print it or over
produce it money being something that
used to get represented by Commodities
by gold by other other other natural
resources
um now it's backed by countries right
it's the Fiat Fiat currencies are backed
by the country essentially is that right
so this is a good question
um what you're basically you know so in
the US dollar bill the full faith and
credit of the U.S government backed by
the full faith and credit of the US
government so the question is what is
the US government
well rothbard said
the state is the social apparatus of
coercion compulsion and violence
so the state is the organization that
derives all its revenues by legally
stealing from other people
so when you ask what backs the US dollar
it's this coercive apparatus we call the
state and
it's our belief that it will remain a
going concern into the future which
means it's our belief that
we will continue to systematically
plunder people through this apparatus
and it will will be a business into the
future that can issue currency and and
prevent others from doing it so in a
business that can't lose is that also
that's right really
that's right and you can and you could
get more specific and say it's the
Central Bank in particular because you
can have a nation state that does not
have a central bank and then they
technically can't plunder you through
currency counterfeiting they can still
plunder you through taxation
um
but yeah when you have a central bank
installed you have a business that can't
lose right if a business
can print money how can you ever lose
money
if you generate a loss well guess what
just print more money and paper over the
loss and you're in the black again
so this is my CPA about this about like
the debt and how this all works and he's
like look it we have enough stuff here
to back up this debt like we have X
amount but he's like look there's a
Breaking Point obviously
yeah and the breaking point
I mean I mean I made him sound really
silly it's actually me that sounds silly
he did a much better job of articulating
it but well it's a consequence of fiat
currency this excess debt accumulation
because when money is being debased or
depreciated over time
everyone is incentivized to borrow the
stronger dollars today
and buy assets
and pay back the weaker dollars over
time
so it's an incentive Distortion and that
incentive Distortion is because the
money's being overproduced if you're on
a gold standard
you're not incentivizing debt
accumulation because gold gets stronger
over time so if I'm gonna I would have
very little incentive to borrow weaker
gold today and pay back stronger gold
over time like May occasionally you have
this incentive if you're in a commercial
business that you know yields
that has an economic yield that outpaces
the actual appreciation of gold but for
consumers we wouldn't want to do this
so
the excess of debt in the world is a
consequence of what I call the
corruption of money
which is the Central centralization and
monopolization of money under the
Central Bank Bitcoin is which is your
area of x one of your areas of expertise
I would not say it's an area of
expertise I don't think anyone's a
billion expert we're all figuring it out
well that's one question is why is it so
complicated is number one back to what
we started talking about the beginning
is that if you can't understand
something well enough you can't really
explain it simply which it seems to be
the case with Bitcoin I have a couple
friends who are really smart and have
learned a lot through about it and
they're like well
it's very complicated and I'm like that
doesn't help me that does not help me
because I have all my money and you know
in dollars and I don't understand but
one of the things I've been asking about
digital currency for years and asking my
financial advisor if we need to
you know allocate some of my you know
wealth in that area and he's like look
we've put in at this point in time he
was like they were working on it and
he's like we put in you know hundreds
and hundreds of hours and we just can't
figure out how someone else isn't just
gonna go make another currency why won't
it get deluded because there will be so
many different digital currencies and so
you know what I'm saying is it's not
necessarily backed by anything other
than scarcity and so
the dollar is essentially backed by
something it seems like at this point
that we have it's not gold anymore but
it's not it's not necessarily
Commodities but we have enough
apparently as a country I'm sure others
do to back up the debt so there is
something there but these digital
currencies are are kind of an artificial
it's a it's a it's an agreement we have
a social agreement that this is worth
something and overtime can be built
through the I always tell everyone I'm
like look money's Just Energy man if you
want to go you want more of it go do
something
and you know there's a scale for all
that but it's essentially the mechanism
so you know how is it that so we can
build you can build anyone any currency
to being a an agreed upon construct to
reflect the energy that you you use to
go do something
um or build something or whatever it may
be so what makes Bitcoin
why do you believe in it
yeah so I love I think this is um I
forget which late night talk show
hostess was but he said take everything
you don't know about money combine
everything you don't know about the
internet and you got Bitcoin basically
so it's it is complicated because well
do you know how the internet works
like
kind of complicated do you know how
money works well I've spent three years
running a show called what is money and
I think it's still complicated right I
don't have a good I have many answers
for you but I don't have one simple
catch-all answer it takes time
an effort to look into it so it's it's
inherently complicated
um
to speak to the advice you received from
your financial advisor I would first
consider this is something you learn
getting into Bitcoin is
there's a saying that no man is better
than his incentives so we have to always
consider that everyone including
ourselves we're always talking our own
book to some extent right
um and it this doesn't this doesn't mean
you can't trust anyone's advice but you
just have to take it with a grain of
salt and understand where they're coming
from
your financial advisor for instance
probably works for one of the big
bracket Banks and he gets his commands
from on high that hey Charlie Munger or
uh uh whoever is it that you know Jamie
dimon whatever guy is at the top of his
bank doesn't like Bitcoin we're not
going to sell Bitcoin we're not going to
talk about Bitcoin we're going to tell
our clients this yeah yeah and so the
criticism that he rendered at Bitcoin
that it's oh we don't understand how it
can be scarce because anyone can copy
and paste this thing and create a new
currency
that's true actually so there's a grain
of Truth in that and it's very difficult
to understand why that's not an actual
threat on bitcoin because to your point
money like language is this social
construct
we you and I could go start Danica Coyne
right now on the ethereum blockchain in
15 minutes and we could go start selling
it online and say this is the next big
currency of the world rah-rah something
else could be valuable other than gold
find something else that there's not a
lot of and call it that you know sure
but the thing is you always end up in
the situation where you're campaigning
for something to become money
versus something emerging naturally as
money right no one ever campaigned for
gold to become money okay it was
selected over time through this Organic
Market process where people are just
choosing the best tool for the job yeah
and gradually they dispense with less
adequate tools you know for a long time
we use silver we use bronze we've used
cattle salt all kinds of things is money
but over time through Market interaction
people learn that well Salt's not as
good as silver silver is not as good as
gold and eventually in the 1800s we're
on basically a universal gold standard
worldwide once the whole world is wired
together by telecommunication networks
the world settles on one monetary
standard so
to say that you can just go copy paste
Bitcoin and create a new one therefore
it's dilutive to bitcoin
I think the analogy that's useful here
is
anyone can change the rules of chess
right we can take the existing game of
chess we can change the rules we can
make pawns be able to move diagonally
and kill going forward right whereas
today they move forward and kill
diagonally or maybe we make the queen a
lot weaker we make the king a lot
stronger whatever we want to do
but when we go and campaign other people
to play chess with us in the world
based on our new rule set who's going to
play with us
right like you it's chess is open source
software English is open source software
I can make up new words right here on
the Fly and to say oh glibity glack it's
a new word and it means a chair sitting
on top of a table right
does that mean anyone's going to use
that word have I changed social
consensus at all I mean I can go out and
like campaign and try to get people to
use the new word maybe I'll succeed
maybe I won't
but there's no
it's not like you just copy and paste
and create a new word and then stick it
in the English language and people start
using it or you copy and paste the rules
of Chess and you tweak a few of them and
then people start playing by them
there's this it has to be an emergent
phenomenon so with Bitcoin we've seen I
think we've had probably close to 50 000
alternative crypto assets which are copy
paste of Bitcoin over the past 14 years
and they've essentially all like with
the I think the exception of two the
last we looked at this over a four year
period they had collapsed in terms of
Bitcoin so
and if you price them in terms of
Bitcoin they had collapsed you know 90
plus percent Society is choosing
this path just like it shows gold or
just like it's choosing it because all
the others are failing and also it is
here to try and it is here for a reason
so what would that reason be yeah and so
a number of things here
it could be strongly argued that Bitcoin
is the only credibly decentralized
project
so it's much more like the internet
itself
like these internet protocols we are
familiar with HTTP tcpip these aren't
companies No One controls them they're
just emergent protocols that were
selected for their usability now the
internet really is that it's just a
stack of Open Source protocols that lets
us move information around the world
without asking permission from anyone
and Bitcoin is just kind of the latest
layer in that Internet Protocol stack
but instead of letting us move
information we can move economic value
without permission
and so you can look at it that way and
say bitcoin's the only truly
decentralized
um protocol everything else is
controlled by someone every other crypto
asset is controlled by someone or some
people some foundation so therefore it's
not decentralized
um another way to look at this is
one really important answer to the
question what is money is what are the
properties people seek in good money
and I've articulated this on a lot of
other shows but so I won't
I want to elaborate on them here but
I'll just mention them people seek a
money that's divisible durable
recognizable portable and scarce like
these are the the the services people
want from a good monetary technology and
historically
monetary metals were the most divisible
durable recognizable and portable
monetary technology available to the
world and of all the monetary metals
that were available gold was the most
scarce
so that's why we selected gold as money
as the best tool for the job over time
here's that same framework to evaluate
Bitcoin we have a technology that's
basically perfected all the properties
of money
so in a way Satoshi left no design space
for another competitive asset to come in
and introduce any Superior feature
you can't like Bitcoin is perfectly
divisible
you know you down it's divisible to 100
million subunits now you can increase
the divisibility with a soft Fork which
is a backwards uh compatible software
update
um
again I don't want to elaborate too much
it's infinitely durable basically it's
distributed information so no one knows
how to get rid of it infinitely portable
because it's just information you can
move it at the speed of light how is
this created then how how was what is
this name again that starts and we don't
really know who he is no one knows who
he is and we just found out that he's a
guy right kind of he identified himself
as a guy so we'll take him out his word
could it be just like an emerging AI
there's a lot of theories out there he's
an alien he's a time traveler yeah who
knows
um but he just released this open source
software project into a chat room of
cypherpunks which are a group of people
that have been trying to crack non-state
digital cash for like 25 years so he
released the project into the right
group that would start to adopt it and
use it and it just grew organically from
there Bitcoin is also perfectly
recognizable because you can audit the
whole Supply and then finally it's
perfectly scarce
in that it's a fixed Supply asset we
don't there's no such thing as a fixed
Supply asset in the physical world you
can't guarantee a fixed Supply but in
the digital world
with Bitcoin you can and that's uh you
know probably harder the 21 million hard
cap
for Bitcoin which is one of its most
important features
because you know you can't be diluted or
debased over time through the printing
and money so it's money we can't print
for someone like myself or probably a
lot of people like what happens with my
money I mean is this somewhat of the
thing that's happening in the world
people are trying to figure out how
they're going to protect their their
wealth it's
in the conventional form that we've
known it so that they don't lose it I
mean because what you're saying then is
that Bitcoin will the the price per coin
will change right
so it can adjust but
so it could expand as far as possible
there's only a certain amount of coins
but well the price yeah the price and
the quantity are different yeah so the
money the supply of circulating Bitcoins
can never exceed 21 million
um now when you talk about a price we
have to remember what we're talking
about we commonly think of price in the
terms of dollars but you can price
anything in terms of anything else it's
just that's a ratio it's a numerator and
denominator right I can price Bitcoin
and Lira I can press Bitcoin and Yen I
can price Bitcoin in pounds I can press
Bitcoin in cars I can price Bitcoin in
tables
it's just how many things does this
thing buy me when you see uh the price
going up this is something I call this a
cognitive optical illusion the US dollar
price of Bitcoin is going up people
think oh bitcoin's becoming more
valuable
and there might be some truth to that
but what you're not seeing is that the
purchasing power of the dollar is also
going down when we print when we
counterfeit new dollars as the Federal
Reserve does by the trillion
you know we call this inflation the
prices of things go up but another way
to look at that and say the same thing
is like well the purchasing power of the
dollar is going down so when the price
of State goes from twenty dollars a kilo
to fifty dollars a kilo that doesn't
mean stake is more valuable or more
widely demanded per se
probably hasn't changed that much
actually like the demand for you know
fixed things like steak people are
probably still eating about the same
amount
who knows Paul saladino might be maybe
he's making beef more popular I don't
know
and liver and liver yeah
but it hides it's this optical illusion
that people don't
again you have to like invert and say oh
well
and this is also tricky for people that
think oh I bought a house
and the property value is going up you
always hear that the value is going up
my equities are going up stocks are
performing really well but it it
disguises the diminishment of the
purchasing power of the US dollar itself
which is also occurring as we print
money
and we have printed a lot of money over
the past three years
um I think roughly 50 percent
of the US dollars in circulation were
produced over the past three years no
way and the Federal Reserve has been
producing dollars since 1913. so 110
years of US dollar production
half of them were produced in the past
three years so if you've met if you
imagine that chart right like a long
steady increase in US dollars in the
past three years is just a vertical line
seems like a you know a bullet train
that just doubled its speed that's right
wall yes that's right and um and of
course you know you hear a lot about
inflation but mainstream media is always
calling it Putin's inflation or uh
supply chain disruptions causing
inflation
I even saw something ridiculous in
Europe that they were saying the Beyonce
concert caused inflation
they'll say they'll assign oh yeah
Taylor Swift and yeah they'll blame
anything other than the mass
counterfeiting of currency that the
Central Bank perpetrates wow
history is political Authority
Central Banking in particular you know
um you could all I mean there's there's
arguments to be made about political
Authority that obviously we need we need
to wield Force
we have to deal with the realities of
physical Force right if someone coerces
or hurts someone well we need some type
of apparatus to deal with that criminal
right you need prisons you need security
Etc
so I wouldn't say political force is
necessarily the scam But Central Banking
is definitely a scam it's just a pyramid
scheme
those that can print money are able to
steal from those who cannot print money
and those who can print money and force
their privilege with guns guns and laws
basically
and so it's a form of legal plunder to
use a term from Bastion has this
happened in history before is there a
track record of what what's happened in
the past if it when on this path yeah
there's a great book by Nick Bhatia my
friend in La it's called layered money
uh very easy read probably two to four
hours and he goes through the history of
Central Banking
um I think it started originally in the
1600s in Antwerp and then the bank of
England was uh a major major Central
Bank for a long time a lot of the reason
a lot of the reasoning behind the
American Revolution was to escape the
grip of the bank of England
and uh and we have the Federal Reserve
here in the United States which again
that book The Creature From Jekyll
Island I think is a must read for
everybody it's a non-fiction book but it
reads like a literary investigation
novel
and it's really really good and so
yeah central banks
increase wealth inequality you're
stealing from the poor and giving to the
rich
a lot of the stolen purchasing power is
used to fund Warfare they typically fund
both sides of the conflicts
um because you can't lose that way right
you're just loaning making loans to both
sides both combatants and a conflict
which obviously drives the scale scope
and severity of warfare
there's a good argument to be made that
neither World War One or World War II
would have been possible at the to the
scope that they were possible without
Central Banking typically a warring
state is confined to their own balance
sheet right they can only afford to
spend on combat what they have in their
Treasury
so they have a war chest as you might
say that is limited
but when you can counterfeit currency
all of a sudden you can steal the
savings of everyone using the currency
so you expand your War chest to the
entire Savings of society
so you can go to war for much longer and
Wars become much more brutal and violent
and you know enduring etc etc
so that's all a consequence of Central
Banking
um I think there's a strong argument to
be made as well that a lot of the
mainstream media [__] propaganda
psyops Corruption of language
all of these uh deceptions we see
propagating in modernity a lot of this
is driven by Central Banking because
you're incentivized to keep the
population confused and divided amongst
themselves such that you can keep
pointing out different Boogeyman for all
the problems all the while you just keep
printing currency taxing them via
inflation
and you keep the scheme going so it's a
classic divide and conquer technique and
so
it's kind of a weird metaphysical claim
but when you make the money [__]
right you make the money a lie it's no
longer what the market selected it to be
the whole world gets Awash in [__]
um had a guess recently that answered
the question
what is money he said it's a symbolic
how did he put this
it's a symbolic structure for the
exchange of Life Energy and so when you
dilute money
you're diluting the exchange of Life
Energy
and in a very real sense when we dilute
money we get a loss of truth right
Society drifts from truth you get all
this mainstream media nonsense that
we're all Awash in today wokism all this
cultural degeneration you get Warfare
so you get real loss of life real loss
of capital and wealth destroyed in war
it's the most expensive and
self-destructive Enterprise humans can
engage in is Warfare nobody wins I mean
you could say the central Bankers win
because they loan to both sides they
collect interests and roll on but no one
like collectively no one wins we we
regress as a species it kind of takes
you back to that big question like what
is money I don't know it's like it's
like the lifeblood of the human species
and so when we corrupt
the money we corrupt our blood and we
suffer from all these socioeconomic
pathologies
and if that's correct then Bitcoin is
Incorruptible money is something that's
very important very important for
creating a sustainable civilization and
a less violent
less violent and less violent human
Enterprise and one that's characterized
with more human flourishing I mean I'd
like to think it's the all the things
that you said would maybe be the
polarity to it but money also it's like
I've thought many times like why don't
we just take money away and trade our
talents you know why don't we you know
if I can build a house then you can do
the plumbing and someone else can do
gardening and plant the vegetables and
you know or the fruits if you're uh Paul
saladino Guy and um like you you know
you can you can trade your your services
um so but you know if there's a lagging
people in in the culture then you know
it could get skewed right so it's kind
of like an honesty it's like almost like
a it keeps people honest if you want to
be able to do something buy something
you need to have done something for the
money to do it to sort of like make the
trade more fair yeah
um but it keeps you honest when the
money's honest right but the money's not
honest the money's not honest because as
you said earlier right we're all working
for dollars everyone that's not a
shareholder of a central bank has to
work to accumulate dollars that's right
you're the shareholder of a central bank
you just hit control p and you have more
dollars
so who is it then like I mean and so the
big Banks own the central bank and the
U.S and then uh and it's very actually
very difficult to uncover who the actual
individuals are that ultimately have
ultimate beneficial ownership of the
central bank but the big Banks own the
central bank and then you could look at
the shareholders of the big Banks
but a lot of a lot of families jump out
immediately that you've probably heard
of the Rothschilds yeah you know yes
exactly exactly so these are families
that have owned a lot of wealth
a majority of the wealth of the human
species for many centuries and um
it's you know purposefully shrouded in
darkness because it's not a pretty
picture do you believe the uh do you
believe in the Titanic Titanic
conspiracy about the guys that were on
the boat were opposing the Federal
Reserve and the ones that wanted it were
not on the boat and one got off just
before or something like that and that's
right yeah so it's a very interesting
Theory I don't know I don't know if it's
true or not
um
esoteric thoughts I thought maybe
conspiracies fell under that oh
definitely I'm very much a conspiracy
theorist people are going to label me
but
we need to re-title conspiracy theorist
by the way it just means ideas that
might be true
well I mean so the original term
conspiracy theorists I think was created
by the CIA post JFK's assassination
right to try and diminish
uh that truth seeking which RFK just
said RFK just said that they killed him
yeah yeah he did yeah we're on a spaces
with him the other day and I've got a
lot to say about that
um again probably related to Central
Banking because JFK had passed an
executive order about three months
before his assassination executive order
11110 that was going to start to take
away power from the Federal Reserve now
who knows again these are speculations
um but the Titanic the further to that
theory I heard that there was a reason
we have restricted private submarine
visitations to the Titanic
because apparently uh there were report
there was reported to be explosions
prior to the boat hitting the iceberg
and so if you could get visual if you
get a visual on the boat and you could
see the blast of the hole going outward
that would confirm that it was an
internal explosion not an not an iceberg
striking it from the outside
and um
there was there was another piece to
this where they talked about the recent
submarine implosion
and how they were going to use that as a
scapegoat to completely prevent any
visitation to the Titanic to try and
bury the conspiracy once and for all
that would make so I don't know look I'm
not saying this is true but interesting
things to think about and when you I
mean it's dark though you get into the
history of money you really and I think
you see this if you kind of stop
and take a breath and really reflect on
yourself and your life experience so far
like don't you see a lot of people
fighting over money chasing money like
it's kind of we're we're animals you
know we're all looking out for our own
self-interest and so if you take that
game to its maximum echelon
to control the money is to effectively
control the world right there's a
Rothschild quote give me the power to
issue a nation's currency I care not who
makes its laws
or said differently he who has the gold
makes the rules so
people that are in pursuit of absolute
power
there is nothing
closer to absolute power than the
control over money
and so I think people have done a lot of
really Dark Twisted things to try and
gain that power
um and it it informs your views about
Warfare you know that we always get
these in school
we're always taught these kind of moral
Crusades why the United States went to
war you know the Civil War was about
slavery or World War II was about
you know bringing democracy here saving
people from Germany or whatever but it's
never actually about that I mean
governments are businesses
they're trying to tax people
uh they go to war occasionally with each
other and the war the purpose of the war
is so that they can expand their
Dominion they want to expand their tax
base
Germany is like I want to capture and
tax more people have more power
and so when you start to see world
history through the lens of money I
think things make a lot more sense like
oh these are just businesses that are
competing with each other but the
business they're in is human coercion
compulsion and violence
so when they compete what does that look
like looks like Warfare
and uh I think it's more corrupt than
ever right now
well I mean my belief is that or more
apparent where animals responding to
incentives so when there are incentives
to be physically violent as there are
under a gold standard where you can
steal gold from someone right you can
conquer them and steal their gold
there's an incentive to be violent there
I think the incentives for violence are
exacerbated when you move on to a Fiat
standard because again
you're not confined to your own War
chest you can now steal the saving you
can hyperinflate the currency and steal
the savings of society to wage war which
is indeed exactly what happened prior to
Hitler
in World War one we had Germany
hyperinflated its currency funding the
war effort and paying for reparations
and From the Ashes of that
hyperinflation Hitler Rose to power
so
like this I think it's incentives that
drive Human Action and this is where
Bitcoin is really important because you
have a dematerialized form of gold
that's really impossible to steal really
difficult to steal let's say via
physical Force
because it's just informational you can
custody any information bearing medium
and so
it's a code right it's a code yeah it's
code so you can think about possessing
Bitcoin is its owning you like
waterboard someone for a code
yeah but here's the thing but like that
code and chop it into multiple pieces
and give it to an undisclosed circle of
trusts right maybe you can it's called a
multi-sip forum okay yeah yeah no no
this is what we like yeah Bitcoin is in
a multi-sig so there are people that
have pieces of the key you can come
waterboard me all you want I can't you
don't know it and you don't know it
exactly I don't have it in his totality
and you don't know who has the rest of
the pieces and you don't know the
protocol necessary for us to come
together and the code words if I tell
them if I call them and I say a certain
word or don't say a certain word then it
tells them what they should or should
not do so it makes it very impossible
like very difficult at least to steal
someone's Bitcoin in that world and so
all of a sudden the incentives of
violence are reduced yeah it's like if
I'm going to spend all this money to go
to war with you or attack you but it's
not carrot at the end of that stick is
smaller then I'm less likely to engage
in coercion or violence so I think that
fundamentally reshapes how humans
organize themselves so I kind of believe
in things from I like look like looking
at the micro and assuming the macro in
this fractal As Above So Below fractal
reality we're living in and it when you
talked about
central government and who's in charge
and the corruption like who is that we
don't really know essentially it's like
almost like the
it's like the it's like the devil inside
that we don't quite know that we're
trying to figure out and that it's an
expression of this Human Experience of
greed of Corruption of a betrayal
um manipulation
um stealing it's just it's a reflection
of us in some way yes you buy into that
yeah well you were hitting the nail on
the head
um I had this realization I had a Joe
dispenza Advanced Meditation Retreat
actually did you like it
there's plenty hours for you yeah almost
exactly what you're saying is one of the
revelations I had and um there's the
classic quote the soldier Nissan right
the line between good and evil cuts down
the heart of every man I hope that
Soulja knitson sometimes confused him in
Dostoevsky but it lives within all of us
all right the potential for good and
evil
and um what you're describing there the
As Above So Below
um
principle I think that
we eat all of us have an ego right and
the ego is kind of this illusion that
we're separate from the world and in
many ways we are right from any
practical purposes
what do they say in the rap song what I
eat don't make you [__] right like I'm
separate from you I have a different
skin boundary different mind different
perceptions conceptions Etc
but there's in a deeper sense we're all
interconnected right we're all breathing
the same air in a energetic vibrational
sense we're all kind of inhabiting the
same reality yeah and so we have this
illusion of separateness within each of
us called the ego and it's useful in
many ways that the Sabertooth tiger
jumps through the window like the ego is
what gets you to get up and run
you were just because you were danger is
yeah if you were just blissed out in
meditation and we're all or one like
that wouldn't be very useful for
propagating the species right you just
get eaten so there's kind of this
necessary illusion inside of us so
that's the microcosm
and I think when you look out into the
macrocosm that the state
is the macrocosm of the ego in a way
there's this illusion of separateness
right that the United States is somehow
separate from China somehow separate
from Canada somehow so when the reality
is we all inhabit one ecology we're in
one Global Marketplace
um you know it's individuals it's a
complex of individuals moving around
these imaginary lines we've drawn on the
land and said no this is this state this
is that state
they're useful fictions but there are
fictions right they're not reality at
all
and so there's literal Line in the Sand
to say this is the separation between
you know that's right yeah and we and we
start to think in terms of that too
right we even say things like oh what is
America going to do it's like there is
no America there's a bunch of
individuals that believe in this
structure called America there's a few
individuals that influence the the
decisions disproportionately right like
politicians you know
Etc
and so
something about overcoming that illusion
of separateness that we have at both the
egoic microcosm and the statist
macrocosm seems to be key
to
having sustainable peaceful loving
relationships and I you know I don't
know what that do we ever get there I
don't know we've I think we've had
evolutions of Consciousness over time
like even today
the idea of private property rights for
instance that an individual can own
something or own you know have a bank
account that is their own 2000 years ago
was a nonsensical idea there was no idea
of the individual there was the
patriarchy patter families the father
owns the family the father can kill his
daughter in broad daylight in the middle
of the street perfectly legal he owns
his family
all this pre-christ Pagan stuff that was
normal well we've evolved over time and
now we have much more sophisticated
moral intuitions and hopefully more
useful
institutions like private property that
help us collaborate and generate more
wealth and
improve our standards of living so I do
believe in our ability to adapt
but we've got a long way to go
um
we're a species it's sort of
obsessed with violence in a lot of ways
like if you watch movies right what are
we doing in movies all the time it's
just
[__] shootings and killings and this
and that and fighting
um Everybody loving their John Wick
movies yeah exactly and I can't help but
Wonder to what extent is that a
consequence of the incentive systems
that we are inhabiting and so quick
fixes porn
yeah you know addiction right yeah you
could argue that fiat currency is an
addiction too because you you always
need more like every
you get diminishing returns on each
round of money printing so that's why we
always print exponentially more money
every time there's a crisis 2008 we
printed 700 billion dollars in 2020 we
printed six trillion dollars right so
10x more
and when you study hyperinflations
historically that's what tends to happen
they print like 10 times more money each
time until eventually the currency just
collapses so
yeah we're Addicted to Money we're uh
We've corrupted it we've used it to
incentivize deception and violence and I
can't help but wonder what the world
would look like if we moved to a world
of honest money
that can't be corrupted can't be debased
can't be stolen via coercion or violence
um how much would that change
the general patterns Of Human Action we
observe in the world and so that's what
gets me really excited for Bitcoin it's
like a new new substrate on which to
build civilization
what do you think of the One World
Government sort of movement that seems
to be happening there's obviously I feel
like a lot of
people with high integrity and spiritual
or open-minded there's just like a
concern for this sort of tyranny
this you know one very very very
top-down system but on the other hand
there's this talk about like we're not
any different and you know it really
isn't a line in the sand that divides
this country in that one and these are
sort of agreements that we have that
sort of make things a little easier
perhaps you can live somewhere where the
rules feel comfortable or whatever it
may be so what are your thoughts about
all of this and
and how the supplies are you know if you
feel if you feel like that's a good idea
or a bad idea well uh the government
that governs best governs least so any
buildup of government power is worse for
the human race no doubt about that
um I would argue that it's again a
symptom of the centralization of money
there's a reason you're hearing so much
about Central Bank digital currencies
these Central
governments especially like one world
central government is not you you could
not ever Implement that without
centrally planning and controlling the
money
that's an indispensable ingredient to
the whole idea of
One World central government so
again I think it's really bad and I
think if you as Humanity moves onto a
Bitcoin standard and we didn't talk
about that a lot today but there's a
kind of a rough
um prediction it's like as currencies
are debased more rapidly people
naturally seek to store their wealth
into something that can't be debased
this is why gold has done so well over
time but gold suffers from all of its
physical limitations
so the theory is people can't stop
printing money the more you print money
the more valuable Bitcoin becomes and
then the more oppressive
and a course of governments become as
they're losing control
you're actually pushing people more into
Bitcoin because people want to control
an asset that no one can take away from
them right right so as governments are
attempting to become more violent more
coercive more extractive well you're
going to naturally have demand for the
asset that is maximally immune to all
that
and so there's this theory that over
time you know we move into like a
bitcoinized world
and I think in a bitcoinized world the
whole notion of One World Government
will just Fall Away really because it
won't be possible it won't it absolutely
won't be possible because you can't
essentially plan and control Bitcoin so
how could you possibly have essentially
planned and controlled government
without essentially planning controlled
money
what about all big control delete
scenario where like what if technology
just goes
like what yeah you know shut the
computers down shut the systems down if
there's one person in charge and they
have no control everyone all they need
to do is send anyone everyone into
you know crisis Anarchy mode and
yeah I mean you can't hold Bitcoin
well so the the question you're asking
is this is a good question for
looking at Bitcoin existentially the
question is
well how do you stop Bitcoin is the
question and then the analogous question
would be how do you turn off the
internet everywhere forever
it's not good enough to just shut it
down here or there even for a short
period of time you need to turn off the
internet everywhere forever
and
we should probably Define the internet
right the the internet is any network of
connected computers so it's not like
there's a thing somewhere that we can
drop a bomb on called the internet and
the internet goes off
the internet is literally the what's the
old saying that the the network is the
computer so the Computing the
connections of computers and individuals
running those computers is the internet
we are actually part of the internet
right we're using it right now we're
we're operating components of the
internet so like like at the end of the
movie Lucy
I haven't seen that one oh man it's
about her being able to use 100 of her
brain by this certain drug that they
found and
you have to watch it
is that uh which actress oh yeah I'm a
big fan of her I'll definitely watch
that
so yeah that's I mean that's it's a hard
question how do you turn off the
internet everywhere forever to the
extent that that is possible Bitcoin
would face an existential threat
um but I don't know I have more
faith in Humanity's resilience
um that as you attack say you start
attacking Central internet providers
well you're creating incentives for
people to create things like mesh
networks where you can have local
internet distribution hubs
um you know the more you censor people
on certain platforms and where you're
creating demand for censorship resistant
platforms
so it's there's always this cat and
mouse game there's a tendency it's like
a low resolution thinking
to be like oh the internet's on or off
it's like well that's not how it
actually works it's where there's
computers that are connected and the
more you try to disconnect computers the
more people start to scramble and
maneuver and reposition themselves to
reconnect computers with other
Technologies so
it seems very unlikely to me that we
would get that
um now you I guess the account argument
here would be
oh what about a solar flare or some type
of global EMP that is permanently wipes
Out All Electronics
I'm like okay if you're going to go to
this total catastrophic scenario well
also everything's [__] in that
scenario your online banking is [__]
all the internet all all your everything
all your electronics they're fried so
if you're planning for that then maybe
bitcoin's not for you but all right you
got bigger problems yeah exactly in that
world
guns and food and all these things
become money pretty quickly and we we
started to generate quickly and we start
over
yeah we would start over yeah I mean how
many times I mean this we're in the what
sixth Extinction they say
I don't know don't know haven't been a
long alive long enough to know which
Extinction we're in yeah I only remember
the last one but you know
that's what they say and like I mean
it's it's a curious thought and
um you know and what causes that too
yeah
yeah well
all the cosmological disasters
notwithstanding I think the best thing
we can do to save ourselves from our own
self-destruction
is to fix the money
I thought you were gonna say therapy
that would also help therapy therapy is
useful too
um and this is the a common Mantra in
Bitcoin circles is fix the money fix the
world
and of course it's an oversimplification
I don't think fixing money fix up fixes
everything I really don't but from an
engineering standpoint I don't think
there's a bigger problem we can solve
and that's why I've tried to commit my
life to
amplifying this message because it seems
like it's pretty obvious but a lot of
people aren't looking at it well fix the
money and earlier we were talking about
sort of more of the symbolism or of
money and
um
and what's that what that's reflecting
within the human experience and so
I would say from a more esoteric
standpoint fix the money fix the fix
your fix your greed fix your fix your
um
uh honesty fix fix the fix the things
that [__] money up yeah and who's gonna
do that anymore then if you fix what the
negative of money
like why do they say money is the root
of all evil well the love of money was
the root of all evil was in the Bible
and
I mean look I'm not a Biblical scholar
but I would say
money is a instrument of worldly
desire right it's
it's a technology it's a tool
if you love worldly things then you're
probably going to be blind to spiritual
things higher principles so I agree with
that the love of my it depends how you
define love and and now in the Bible
oftentimes when the word love is used
it's talking about Agape which is like
the highest form of Christian love the
Selfless Love you have for your newborn
child
um there's so three Greek words I know
of that are used for Love Is
Eros which is consumptive love where we
get words like erotic but it can mean
like I love steak I want to consume the
steak right
uh there's philia which is more like
family or friendship love
where you want ongoing reciprocal
opening right I want to get to know you
more deeply such that you get to know me
more deeply such that I can know you
more deeply I don't want to eat my
friends hopefully right so it's not Eros
it's phylia and then Agape is this
Selfless Love where you come home with
your newborn child
they're not even there's not even
reciprocity right they're just kind of
an inert a little lump yeah you love
them more than anything you've ever love
you've ever experienced so it Agape
would be inappropriately attached to
money in my estimation so if that was if
that was a form of love being used in
that passage which I'm not sure you'd
have to check the Greek translation I
would say that makes sense that would be
the root of all evil if you had total of
you know self-abanding love for money
well then you've got some problems then
you do need some therapy in that case
well it's definitely abandoning morals I
mean I would think that that's a very
common problem with money is the
abandons morals it abandons
um but another way to say what you were
just saying I think is again fix the
money fix the world you could translate
that to fix the incentives fix the world
and we're back to that idea of
our individual characters and our paths
of moral development
are an emergent property of the
incentive structures we inhabit
so if I live
tens of thousands of years ago and I was
a hunter and gatherer
it would be very moral for me to be an
excellent spear thrower right people
would appreciate that I would be
celebrated because I could go and I
could hunt I can break down big animals
and I can feed the tribe that would be
like one of the most celebrated skill
sets well in 2023 I mean maybe if you're
in the Olympics throwing Javelin you
could get celebrated for that but you're
not going to be celebrated I'm not going
to make a lot of money off that exactly
so it's there's as the incentives change
based on our Tech the technological
realities we're inhabiting so too to our
moral appraisals of one another and and
uh you know what skills and talents and
character traits are
prized and rewarded so it's interesting
to think about
what an honest money world could look
like all of a sudden we're violence and
these things just they don't pay they're
not profitable
so they wouldn't be as celebrated I
don't think we would celebrate people
Statesmen right well like Biden or Putin
or any of these other guys now that we
celebrate them that much anymore anyways
but historically we have and we'd
celebrate entrepreneurs more like the
people that actually create useful goods
and services for the world those would
be our Elites right we would have
entrepreneurial Elites versus political
Elites and that seems like that would be
a really good thing for for human humans
absolutely I mean I completely agree
with that I I wonder what happens to the
government without Central Banking
I mean just take taxes for instance I
feel like I've seen things in the past
where people look very hard for the
actual legal language to support needing
to pay taxes and that they these these
you know these IRS agents can't find it
and then they just decide to stop paying
taxes because they can't find the actual
language but then the mafia comes after
you hmm
so um absent a central bank governments
are Central governments Federal
governments are constrained they can't
they can't print money to paper over
losses so their growth is constrained
and now
your only forms of revenue for a state
with the Central Bank you have inflation
so you can print money to generate
Revenue
if you can't print money so you don't
have a central bank the only thing you
can do is taxation
so you have to go or you could also
borrow that's not technically Revenue
but you could you could Finance
government initiatives through borrowing
which we've done a lot right we used to
sell Bonds in Wartime and all that
but now you go from a situation where
with inflation you just print money and
then you blame everyone else for prices
going up you know it's Putin's fault
it's Beyonce's fault it's whoever's
fault and people don't understand what's
going on they don't understand they're
being robbed by the central bank
when you remove the Central Bank the
government now has to go to individuals
and say hey
uh you know for instance the Iraq war in
the US we're blowing up people on the
other side of the world and uh your
share of that bill is eighty thousand
dollars you know please send your check
here and people will be like what the
[__] is this like no I'm not you know
it's it's explicit taxation versus
implicit Taxation and the more explicit
taxation is the more resistant people
are to it because they can see it you
see the bill and you see what it's
funding right you see what the
government's doing with it and you see
how much they're charging you and so
people become much more resistant in
that world that constrains government
growth
so that's obviously a good thing
I can't see how it continues
or it just starts over again I mean
if they don't have money essentially to
do anything
what
yeah it becomes like a normal business
if you're if you're p l if you're not if
your profit and loss statement is not
profitable
well then you start selling off pieces
of the business until you become
profitable right you have to shrink
until you become profitable
and so all the rampant government
overspending we have again it's an an
incentive problem
when you can produce money out of thin
air of course you're going to spend it
recklessly of course
if I had a money printing machine on my
table I would probably spend it
recklessly too
like it doesn't cost me anything to
produce the money yet I can go out into
the world and acquire things that cost
other people time effort energy totally
we play the game fairly right
essentially we do something we get money
we trade favors to get favors exactly
hunting favors out of thin air exactly
it must catch up to him at some point
and it sounds like it has I hope so I
don't I mean when you really look at it
and so I call it the biggest Con in
human history is the biggest pyramid
scheme in human history in terms of
purchasing power stolen I have a piece I
wrote called Masters and slaves of money
that actually
develops a proxy for the number of human
hours stolen through money printing
um and I you know I've been criticized
heavily for saying this but I don't know
what else you call systemized time theft
other than slavery
right it's not whips and chains and
picking cotton kind of slavery
but you're still in hours and working
energy and effort from people even
though it's in this shadowy kind of
implicit manner it's still time theft
you're still strap them with the silly
TV shows and reds and circuses politics
and reds and blues and or bread and
circuses I think is what they call that
an ancient Rome totally as long as you
give people bread and circuses they
don't care about what's going on I was
just in Rome and went to the Coliseum
and it's like
so they did they I can't remember
exactly how many hundred days in a row a
thousand they they went on and on and
had these games every day for so many
days yeah and you get they get their
bread they have their circus it
distracts from whatever else is going on
is there a is there a um uh
a governing structure that has been the
most successful in history or are we
still learning well you know
conventional wisdom today is that
democracy is the greatest governance
structure ever created
um however
I think it has many problems there's a
great book on this you could just read
the introduction in chapter one to this
book and get the gist of it
it's titled democracy The God That
Failed by Hapa h-o-p-p-e is the author's
last name
really good book uh dense and kind of
difficult but he makes a case that
monarchy actually has many advantages
over democracy and uh the Monarch for
instance
typically it's a hereditary hereditary
monarchy right so the Father the king
runs the kingdom and then he passes it
on to a son who passes it on to the
grandson
there's a long-term interest then in the
Integrity of that Society because I know
that my son is going to get it and his
grandson's going to get it so now the
people that I'm governing right the
Baker and the blacksmith Etc
I'm aligned with them because they're
passing their businesses on in a
hereditary fashion too so our son's
interests are aligned our grandson's
interests are aligned and so you start
to think really long term you don't want
to over tax the population because they
will revolt and kill you because it's
very clear who runs the monarchy you
don't want to go to war too much because
you will bankrupt the monarchy and you
would that's the end of your business
your son wouldn't would not inherit
anything
and so there's kind of this system of
checks and balances in this long-term
orientation and when you contrast that
to democracy
there's a great quote about democracy it
says every public election is an
advanced auction on stolen goods we vote
these people into power for four to
eight years they cut as many deals as
they can to get as many Kickbacks and
whatever and then they just literally
pass all like filling the whole all of
society with hidden risks and problems
and then they just check out of office
and pass all that on to the next guy
and so the next guy is doing the same
thing it's just this like there's an
incentive for short-termism
and plundering that exists in democracy
that does not exist inside of a monarchy
um and when you combine that with
Central Banking right systemic theft
through currency to basement
um yeah I think democracy is a terrible
idea actually and what does the future
look like on a Bitcoin standard maybe
something more like digital monarchies
where there's just little free private
cities
that have different
um
agreements between them right like if
you're a citizen of one city maybe you
have reciprocity with 50 other cities
that you can travel to
uh you would pay them some fixed fee
presumably versus being taxed on your
income or capital gains Etc you just pay
for Hey look it's like a it's like being
a member at a club I'll just pay you my
membership fee once a year and you don't
need to know how much money I make you
don't need to know what I do you don't
need to know anything about me you just
need to know that we have a contract and
I paid it and when I'm here I expect
these Services right I get security
property rights whatever it may be oh
yeah and just pay a fee yeah so you move
from a world of Taxation to a world of
just security fees and
um
yeah but the world would be a lot more
prosperous because people would be able
to keep the fruits of their labor and
the extent to which people can keep the
fruits of their labor is the extent to
which they can flourish
um and yeah would be a world hopefully
again with less theft less violence and
less deception well I was going to ask
you about Trump because
you know with election stuff and I'm
sure you're not going to be divisive
about anything but it would be said that
he is more of a businessman and that
essentially like the country was
financially more successful with him so
should the country not be run like a
business then I mean again I'm going to
go back to just the failings of
democracy there I don't think there's
any human you can put in the the Oval
Office that will really improve things
do you think it really matter
I don't we talked about JFK earlier like
I sort of consider him the last real
President we had because he was
what's that saying that for every
thousand striking at the leaves there's
one strike at the root and he was
striking at the root of problem he's
like no the Federal Reserve is a problem
let's start to take power away from the
Federal Reserve that that is the most
important first step to restoring you
know freedom and Truth in the world and
JFK was taking that step and he was
assassinated shortly thereafter so every
president since then I think has been
just hacking at the leaves at best got
it all right well then what do we do
what do we do to what would be your
recommendation for someone like me who
has no digital currency I have no
Bitcoin I have nothing everything is in
dollars like what happens to someone's
wealth if it's in dollars at this point
in time I guess first of all I'll say is
I never want to be prescriptive about
what someone should do with their wealth
right it's each of us has our own unique
situation risk tolerance blah blah blah
um
I encourage people to study Bitcoin
I did not say buy Bitcoin
I said study Bitcoin
and study the nature of money I think
these are very useful intellectual
Explorations and it pulls back a lot of
veils that we've we've been conditioned
to think of things in a certain way you
know again we talked about like the
moral excuses for Warfare that we hear
in school you know the Civil War is here
to stop slavery it's like no that's not
true that's a story about money and
Taxation
so you can see through that [__]
just by studying money the nature of
money
um so that's like that's my
recommendation actually it's not it's I
guess you could say it's Financial
advice because the studying will change
the way you you construct your portfolio
it'll change the way you manage your
time it'll change the way you invest in
yourself
but I'm not here to advocate for any
particular position including Bitcoin I
just advocate for Bitcoin because
of all of the the features that I think
it offers
Humanity right as a civilization
and then I guess just to
speak to your last question there
yeah if you're holding your wealth in
dollars you're holding an asset that can
be readily counterfeited by a central
bank so
you have to question how scarce and
valuable those dollars will remain over
time
versus holding something that cannot be
readily counterfeited like physical gold
or Bitcoin or even stocks right stocks
can't be counterfeited typically as
rampantly even bonds are more scarce
than dollars that's not to say dollars
don't have use right I hold dollars too
um I typically just use them for working
capital for my businesses and then I
keep my long-term savings and harder
assets
[Music]
um but again since our assets are
probably a good idea at this point in
time just in transition phase I expose
right yeah buy something in dollars now
and essentially someone could buy it
from you in Bitcoin in the future and
essentially you're collaterally moving
as opposed to having to start over in
some kind of way or sort of not get as
much for your money yeah and just also
be cognizant of counterparty risk which
is
a lot of things we think we own we
really just have a promise to the thing
this includes the dollars in your bank
you don't own the dollars in your bank
you have a creditor debtor relationship
with the bank you have loaned them the
dollars they might pay you the dollars
back or they might default all right
we've seen Banks go under saw a lot
going to this year if you look
historically it's really bad like Banks
go under all the time so don't get
lulled into this false sense of
confidence that the numbers on my online
banking are my numbers and like they're
always going to be there
good uh stocks as well stocks get over
issued going to buy boats gonna buy more
houses yeah even those things right real
estate like we think I own the house
well try not paying your property taxes
for a few years and you'll find out who
really owns the house
um wow you got to consider counterparty
risk and everything that you own and so
the only thing that you can own free of
a counterparty is what's called a bearer
asset right
the gun that you keep in your house the
physical gold you have in your backyard
the Bitcoin you have in self-custody
these things are bearer assets there's
no counterparty you hold it and control
it and possess it directly
and that's uh you know you need
definitely need some direct control over
some assets
in case things get bad because you don't
want to be left holding a bunch of
promises
when people start to break their
promises all right well thank you that's
some good advice I really basically just
get the total understanding that once
you understand what's really going on
you will reframe everything and it will
lead you in the right direction yeah
Bitcoin is a heck of an intellectual
rabbit hole and it will change the way
you see everything well if
it out it's uh I've already got started
I'll take that as a compliment thank you
it was for sure you're very smart
thank you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button